يمضغونه هنا يمضغونه
هناك يمضغونه إلى حد كبير في كل مكان
أظهرت الدراسات اليمنية أن ما يصل إلى 90٪ من
الرجال و 70٪ من النساء يستخدمون
قطعه يوميًا له تأثير مشابه
للأمفيتامينات ووسط تنبؤات رهيبة
بحدوث مجاعة في اليمن
أكبر محصول في البلاد هو سوق القطط بالسونار
4،000 10،000 15،000 25،000 أي 5 دولارات
لأرخص حقيبة قطة يمكنك إطعام
عائلة ليوم كامل
بسعر أرخص قطع لديك ، هل تعتقد أنه من
المنطقي بالنسبة لليمن الذي لا يحتوي على طعام
كل شخص يمضغ لا
معنى له ،
يمكن للعائلة البسيطة أن تنفق 5 دولارات
لتناول الطعام ، فهل من المدهش إذن أن
اليمن يعاني من مشكلة الجوع
ما هي المشكلة إنها كارثة
لا يمتلكها اليمن ممزق بسبب
الحرب  الشمال تحت الحصار
سوف يتم إطعام اثني عشر مليون يمني من قبل برنامج الغذاء العالمي التابع للأمم المتحدة
هذا العام. وزراء المتمردين الحوثيين
على دراية بالمشكلة ولكن
بسيط جدًا معظم
أراضيكم يتم تخصيصها لزراعة الأدوية وليس الغذاء ، لذا
أهلاً إه ج  أنا أتفق معك ، فهذه
عادة سيئة يجب أن نتخلص منها
وهي أمر لا جدال فيه ، فلدينا
برامج حكومية لمكافحة النمو الذي
يتم صيده ، ونزيل الأشجار التي تم صيدها ونزرع أشجار حبوب البن ،
وبدلاً من ذلك
، تم الاستيلاء على المزارع الجبلية في اليمن والمدرجات عن
طريق القطط ،
إنه كذلك  من المهم بالنسبة لليمنيين أنه
يتم توصيله في اليوم الذي يتم فيه اختياره في جميع
أنحاء البلاد بسرعات فائقة
للمستهلكين ، حيث يتم تخصيص ثلث جميع
الزراعة للمصنع
الذي يستهلك ثلث إجمالي المياه
للزراعة منذ 25 عامًا تم زراعة هذا الوادي بالكامل
القمح لكن المزارعين
يقولون إن هذا مجرد محصول واحد في السنة الآن
يحصلون على أربعة محاصيل سنويًا من هذا
المخدر وفي أوقات الحرب يكون المحصول النقدي
هو ما يهم حقًا ، فنحن نحقق فقط
ربحًا من قطع المحاصيل الأخرى ولا
نغطي نفقات المنزل.  هذا هو المحصول الوحيد
الذي سيغطي نفقاتنا اليومية والسنوية
، وتقدر وزارة الزراعة
اليمنية أن اليمنيين ينفقون 12 مليارًا سنويًا
على العقار ، أي حوالي ثلاثة أضعاف
المبلغ.  تقول الأمم المتحدة إنها بحاجة لمساعدة
اليمن. هذه الأرقام تتحدث عن نفسها
سام كيلي سي إن إن صنعاء